la victoire contre le groupe etat
islamique a des airs de fin du monde
pour éliminer les djihadistes ce sont
des villes et des villages entiers qui
ont été rasés les forces démocratiques
syriennes
un groupe arabo kurde appuyée par la
coalition internationale n'est plus qu'à
un kilomètre du dernier des
retranchements de dèche un tout petit
territoire de moins de 1 kilomètre carré
la bataille fait du surplace depuis
quelques jours
alors là je trouve important dans le
monde amis et l'humour et yeux des shsh
est entremêlé à la population civile
d'une ahmed
les combattants se servent des civils
comme boucliers humains pour empêcher
les avions de les frapper
mohamed affirmé que des négociations
sont en cours pour permettre de faire
libérer les civils et des otages cure de
retenue par les combattants
tous veulent vicois aux plus grands
honneurs ils n'ont nulle part où aller a
affirmé le porte parole de l'opération
al jazira la zone est petit mais les
civils nous pose un problème moral
nous allons reprendre les combats mais
nous ne voulons pas les mettre en danger
dans cette partie de ben arous tout
juste reprise c'est maintenant le
drapeau des fds qui flottent on ne
retrouve plus que des traces du monde
qui avait construit le i leur sigle
peint sur les murs de cette école
coranique détruites
la monnaie qu'ils avaient frappé
moi même nous guide dans les décombres
ici il nous montre ce qui est l hôpital
du groupe etat islamique
l'état des lieux scabreux le sol jonché
de seringue de pansements souillée
d'excréments humains
témoin de ce que l'on imagine avoir été
des derniers moments particulièrement
difficiles pour les combattants
djihadistes qui de toute évidence
n'osait plus quitté leurs positions
même pour se soulager
ce sont les explosifs de dèche nous
montre ce jeune soldat de l'accord dit
une poudre explosive à base de
nitroglycérine
autant de munitions explosives qui
étaient destinés à des opérations
suicide contre eux ce n'est qu'une
question d'heures sinon deux jours avant
qu'on puisse officiellement annoncé la
fin du califat comme entité géographique
ce projet food aboubaker al bagdadi qui
s'étendent à une époque rappelez-vous
sur un territoire aussi vaste que la
grande-bretagne à cheval entre la syrie
et l'irak
un projet qui a mobilisé pour lutter
contre le groupe armé islamique tout une
coalition internationale est ici au nord
de la syrie cette force arabo kurde et
forces démocratiques syriennes ne se
font aucune illusion si elle convient
déclaré la victoire contre dèche
elles savent très bien que l'idéologie
elles demeurent et que des milliers de
combattants sont toujours au large
en après midi mardi les fds annoncé être
sur le point d'évacuer des civils et des
combattants qui veulent se rendre
des dizaines de véhicules vides se met
en route vers le dernier réduit de lui
mais peu de temps après leur passage
il est évident que l'exfiltration
annoncée n'aura pas lieu
pas aujourd'hui
le son des armes et l'explosion de
bombes larguées par ce biais américain
mais de fait à tout espoir d'évacuation
l'annnonce de la victoire est toujours à
l'horizon pour les fds mais il devra
attendre un autre jour ici marie-eve
bédard radio-canada à bakou zalfa cas ni
dans le nord-est de la syrie